parís
[Música]
bienvenidos a corresponsables dedicamos
esta emisión especial a la noticia
internacional del momento la invasión de
las tropas rusas a ucrania justificada
por el presidente vladimir putin para
-según sus palabras- desmilitarizar y
desclasificar a ucrania en medio del
avance de las tropas de moscú en
distintos puntos de ucrania los
ciudadanos se han sumado a los esfuerzos
de resistencia de mí pero la tercera
ciudad del país cuenta con un ejército
de voluntarios que se preparan para
intentar detener a los soldados rusos el
siguiente es un reportaje de katrina
restraint maíz agua y julián sin gas
en la plaza de la ciudad ucranianos
cargando cajas de bombonas de gasolina
caseras siguiendo las instrucciones del
gobierno para defender sus hogares
elgeta estos son para hacer cócteles
molotov esta es la única manera posible
de protegernos a nosotros mismos a
nuestros hijos a nuestros padres y
abuelos y a todos nosotros
desde el inicio de la invasión rusa los
ciudadanos de libro en el centro de
ucrania organizan una resistencia a poca
distancia los voluntarios se alistan en
masa para unirse a las fuerzas de
defensa territorial y comienzan a
trabajar en las defensas de la ciudad
dejando atrás sus trabajos y familias
entiendo que ahora mismo no debo ser un
simple fisioterapeuta o médico debo ser
un soldado que apunta a nuestro enemigo
con una kalashnikov destruiremos a este
enemigo estoy preparado y mis hijos y mi
mujer también lo están
y hay muchos como el guardias de
seguridad empresarios que ahora prestan
apoyo al ejército ucraniano aunque
algunos nos dicen que han recibido poca
formación y les falta equipo nombres
brollo
al diámetro que movemos
los cuatro nos han dado algunas armas
pero no tenemos suficientes chalecos
antibalas ni cascos
queremos que nuestros socios europeos y
americanos nos ayuden
aquí llegan algunos suministros no es
material militar sino cualquier cosa que
los residentes locales pueden conseguir
para ayudar al esfuerzo bélico de
ucrania
los voluntarios se apresuran a organizar
frenéticamente las donaciones de ropa
mantas y alimentos que se enviarán a los
soldados voluntarios y hospitales
estamos preparados y sabemos que rusia
no esperaba que nuestra nación se
levantará tan rápida y activamente tanto
la gente corriente como los actores
cantantes y directores de cine han
dejado sus casas y están ayudando a la
defensa territorial mientras las tropas
rusas avanzan los ciudadanos de esta
ciudad están haciendo un esfuerzo siendo
un símbolo de la resistencia popular
calificada es una ciudad que en tiempo
normal queda aproximadamente a unas tres
horas por carretera al suroeste de kiev
aquí los voluntarios preparan blindajes
para el ejército mientras que otros
mandan paquetes de comida que han sido
regalados por la propia población local
la gran mayoría de sus voluntarios son
mujeres ya que los hombres han sido
llamados al frente de combate el
siguiente es un reportaje de gulliver'
crac
estamos en cali nov acá una pequeña
ciudad que en tiempo normal queda a más
o menos 3 horas en carretera al suroeste
de que esos voluntarios preparan
blindajes para el ejército otros mandan
paquetes de alimentos que regala la
población local sólo hay mujeres aquí
porque los hombres están llamados al
frente todo el mundo se está movilizando
incluso mi padre va a ir cada uno hace
lo que puede nosotros apoyamos
hacemos lo que podemos pero si no nos
ayudas ellos serán los siguientes en
atacarte es cierto
queremos que occidente nos ayude porque
la ayuda llegó muy tarde demasiado tarde
se hubieran introducido sanciones en el
2014 todo sería diferente
putin no habría empezado esta guerra y
ahora es un poco tarde pero más vale
tarde que nunca
no podemos vivir bajo el control de otro
país así que solo tenemos la opción de
elegir entre la victoria o la muerte
lucharé como un samurai y puede que me
maten pero no viviría bajo el mando de
putin vivir en un país libre si han
escogido este lugar para trabajar es
porque en el edificio de atrás el azul
hay un refugio y los tiroteos se hacen
escuchar hasta aquí montón con respecto
a mí si durante estos días de conflicto
france24 ha ido directamente en el
terreno al encuentro de ciudadanos
ucranianos para que expresen sus
sentimientos ante esta crisis muchos de
ellos se debaten entre el miedo y el
deseo de defender a su país
los diplomáticos deben hacer su trabajo
y dejar a la gente común fuera de esto
son los que deben resolver este
conflicto en la ciudadanía debería poder
disfrutar de sus vidas ir al trabajo los
niños seguir yendo a la escuela
me gusta vivir aquí y no me quiero ir
prefiero quedarme aquí antes que dejar
quiero otra ciudad de ucrania en todo
caso no quiero dejar este lugar
en el 2014 nuestra ciudad fue
fuertemente bombardeada y no queremos
que eso pase de nuevo solo como no les
daremos nuestra ciudad tan fácilmente
nuevos
pelearemos por esto que lo vean entonces
sabrán cómo nos sentimos que nos tengan
miedo los rusos
estoy listo para pelear por mi ciudad
en kiev unos 200 pacientes se encuentran
ingresados en el hospital infantil más
importante del país allí las autoridades
han tenido que improvisar búnkeres para
proteger a niños con problemas
oncológicos mientras que los heridos
siguen llegando el siguiente es un
reportaje de nuestras enviadas
especiales a la capital ucraniana irene
sabio y leticia lores
oksana tiene 31 años y es madre de saya
un niño de 6 años que tiene una
disfunción renal y necesita hemodiálisis
llegó aquí hace cuatro meses y su hijo
no puede abandonar el hospital nos
fuimos de la biacs no porque fuera
peligroso sino para curar a mi hijo
books and explica que no tuvo otra
opción mi familia está preocupada por mí
por mi hijo pero yo no puedo volver a
slavia ahora me tengo que quedar aquí en
quien salsa es uno de los 200 pacientes
ingresados en este centro hospitalario
entiende que opera bajo las bombas y es
el más importante del país un hospital
que ha tenido que armar búnkeres
improvisados para mantener a salvo a sus
pequeños pacientes tenemos algunos
lugares seguros donde los protegemos de
las bombas en los subterráneos y no es
bueno para los niños con problemas
oncológicos porque no hay buena
ventilación hay muchísimas personas hay
poca agua y poca libertad de movimiento
y por tanto hay riesgo de infecciones el
médico subraya que el problema número
uno en la guerra
a causa de la guerra no podemos dar una
atención médica adecuada a los niños en
todas partes hay disparos problemas
distintos tipos de problemas tenemos a
cuatro niños que han llegado heridos un
niño murió antes de llegar a nuestro
hospital y otro sufrió una muerte
clínica poco después de ser ingresado
rumbo
pero no solo los niños sufren
todos los niños al igual que los padres
están en una situación muy difícil
porque la guerra es un gran estrés para
ellos nos faltan medicinas no nos llegan
y el problema no es sólo de los niños
sino también de los padres que necesitan
tranquilizantes para afrontar estos días
la mayor sorpresa fue la de encontrarse
ante un conflicto que nos esperaban
la guerra fue inesperada a nosotros
mismos no podemos entender cómo pudo
ocurrir
un drama que no afecta sólo a un niño
del hospital o inmediato según en sed en
ucrania las hostilidades son una amenaza
inmediata para 7,6 millones de niños
la incursión militar rusa en ucrania ha
generado temores entre otras naciones ex
soviéticas como por ejemplo los países
bálticos estonia letonia y lituania que
a diferencia de ucrania hacen parte de
la otan estos países han pedido la
activación del artículo 4 de la alianza
transatlántica este artículo prevé
consultas inmediatas cuando uno de los
miembros se siente amenazado informe de
leticia álvarez e irene saudí
la orden teniente sin novedad en el
sitio de tiro
mire ya tiene 23 años y es una sargento
española destinada en la misión de la
otan en letonia su posición es táctica
con su pelotón entrena para disparar en
primera línea de fuego para mí es un
orgullo estar aquí representando a
españa además a la otra y trabajar como
unidad con la que estado trabajando
estos seis meses anteriores
pues también es como sueño cumplido como
parte de periodo el grupo táctico
multinacional de batalla con base en
letonia está liderado por canadá y
albergan nueve nacionalidades distintas
el coronel sanders gaubert es el
comandante de la brigada mecanizada
letona al cargo de la base de
la misión se creó hace cinco años para
disuadir y defender es simple todo está
relacionado con la disuasión pero al
mismo tiempo si las cosas van mal es una
misión de defensa aquí
gordon
la lección rusa de crimea precipitó la
creación de tres batallones
internacionales en los países bálticos
que empezaron a operar en 2017
la situación del conflicto de ucranianos
llegó al punto de empezar a pensar en
cómo podemos defender nuestro país ahora
un cáncer y cada movimiento que hace
putin en esta frontera de los bálticos
pone en alerta a toda la región la otan
ha reforzado el flanco oriental polonia
bulgaria también ha mandado efectivos
aéreos a estonia lituania y no se
descarta todavía un refuerzo mayor los
observadores cargamos posiciones del
objetivo así que ellos están
reconociendo los objetivos pasando la
información a los camiones calculando
los datos y mandan en sus datos a la
línea de disparo los adiestramientos en
la base de la otan de letonia son
continuos en este caso entrena en el
lanzamiento de proyectiles
tu continuidad por training vamos a
continuar con nuestro entrenamiento
intensificaremos nuestra preparación
continuaremos compartiendo información
con nuestros socios y estaremos
preparados para apoyar a cualquier país
miembro de la otan ya la región
worten y nate el canto y la otra en
aumento su presupuesto desde que estalló
la guerra en el este de ucrania y aunque
sólo diez países cumplen con la
aportación del 2% de su pib esta cifra
ha ido en aumento
gracias por seguir esta nueva emisión de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom